there are two very distinct moments that
I was inspired by to write this book one
I do a lot of work in the women's in
politics space so I got a call from an
organization to come up with a website
that for women's get-out-the-vote day
and I said great and I sent it out to
the designer and it came back pink full
of flowers and I said there's really
something missing here like this is not
what I why I'm involved in politics is
because I'm you know one everything pink
this is very very weird and they said no
no this is what we want we want to
really be upbeat and sort of girly and I
said I like being up being girly but it
doesn't have to be pink and frivolous I
mean I think about being a woman as
being very strong I think Hillary
Clinton has definitely submitted that
into all of our minds and and the next
part of our conversation was oh we're
having a woman's get-out-the-vote day a
Latino get-out-the-vote day it disabled
people get out the vote day and I was
thinking women are the gender gap in the
last from every election since nineteen
sixty we have decided every president
more women have voted the men we are not
a niche audience we are not a special
interest we are the interest that needs
to be catered to so okay how do you
communicate different differently with
women than you do men so that was the
first story the second story is I was up
on the Upper East Side of New York at a
large donor event for a gentleman who is
running for president I'm not a large
dinner myself that I was invited to be
in this very exclusive room mostly with
Wall Street guys and I I said you know
mr. want to be President what do you
think issues are important to me and he
looked me right in the eye and he said I
know that protecting you know the
woman's right to choose and Families
that's what's really important to you
and I thought you know yeah it's really
important to me but it's like 14th on my
list like I want us to get out of Iraq I
want to have a stronger economy I want
universal health care so these
assumptions that a all women are pink
and be that we only care about abortion
just like blew my mind so I started
doing some research on what the private
sector have been doing because you know
in the political and nonprofit world we
often are looking at trends and there's
a bunch of really seminal information
out there about how corporations have
really changed how they
market women make eighty-three percent
of the consumer decisions we are fifty
nine percent of the primary voters we
volunteer more than women do a more than
men do we have 51 percent of the wealth
we're really the ones who have the power
to change the world yet I think we and
we and men are sort of stuck in this old
paradigm that says it's a man's world
it's not and it's not that women want it
to be a woman's world we wanted to be a
man and woman's world together so i
started doing research for this book and
i said it has to be written and I want
it to be the first book ever that really
addresses this from a political and a
non-profit section and and and my
co-author Lisa Chen and I have been in
this nonprofit work for over 25 years so
we're able to get case studies from you
know the NRDC and code pink and women
for women international so we're to
highlight our expertise and really give
concrete advice about how to communicate
differently with women the men
you